[Musique]
une nouvelle manifestation ce mercredi
des agriculteurs du sud-yvelines ont
défilé aujourd'hui avec leur tracteur à
Paris il dénonce l'arrêt brutale de
l'usage des néonicotinoïdes un pesticide
pour les cultures de betterave qui
empêchent la jaunisse une maladie virale
propagée par les pucerons la filière
pensée bénéficier d'une dérogation comme
cela était prévu au total une vingtaine
de tracteurs du département rejoint par
des tracteurs d'Eure-et-Loir sur son
retrouvés au niveau d'Ablis pour se
rendre à la capitale pour rejoindre plus
de 500 tracteurs et 2000 paysans un
déménagement à présent la société Airbus
va quitter la clé de Saint-Pierre à
Élancourt pour s'installer à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux dans le quartier
du pas du lac à l'horizon 2027 en cause
le manque de transport en commun dans la
zone élancourtoise et un bail qui
arrivait à expiration le groupe
d'aéronautique et de défense va lancer
des études en vue de la réalisation de
ce nouveau site à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
les travaux devraient s'acheter fin 2026
au total 2700 salariés sont concernés à
Coignières l'association pharmacie
citoyen fondée par Mustapha lahbaoui a
organisé me dit un goûter sale
Saint-Exupéry l'idée était de réunir les
enfants et les parents de neuf club
locaux de football amateurs partenaires
de l'association retrouvé par exemple
les présidents des clubs de Guyancourt
Élancourt au plaisir l'objectif était
également de présenter les sorties
organisées par la structure sur la
citoyenneté les valeurs de la République
on fait 30 sorties au total je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure à 4 mini bus à chaque
fois
cinq destinations
c'est quasiment 80000 km par an et bien
ça sert c'est sorti son éducatifs et
j'aime bien ça fait plaisir de penser
aux petits enfants comme nous voilà
c'est c'est cool de ouf c'est trop bon
2024 les organisateurs ont présenté ce
mercredi l'identité visuelle de chaque
discipline avec les différents
pictogrammes et les couleurs dominantes
de la compétition le rose le bleu le
violet et l'or seront les couleurs qui
habilleront les sites les villes et les
partenaires en 2024 les Yvelines vont
accueillir le cyclisme sur piste le BMX
Maurice le VTT le golf l'équitation le
marathon le pentathlon moderne le
cyclisme sur route on termine par de la
box chez les lots en connaît enfin la
date du combat entre livinois Tony yokai
Carlos Takam l'affrontement est
programmé le 11 mars au Zénith de la
Porte de la Villette à Paris un choc de
style en perspective entre les deux
boxeurs Tony hawka 30 ans 11 victoires
et une défaite va affronter un vétéran
de 42 ans qui compte 39 victoires 7
défaites et un nul le boxeur originaire
de Chanteloup-les-Vignes aura à cœur de
se rattraper après sa première défaite
chez les professionnels contre Martin à
bas collé en mai dernier
[Musique]